Those are things we don't want in the
United States. And one other thing,
predatory behavior,
I got mad at me, but if I could say
this, it's not baked into their religion.
Trump's support supporters. Can I
have you over there? My immigrants?
Can I have you in the other leg?
Yeah.
Sometimes I feel anxious about
how the other side views me.
Hmm.
Uh, so it's not necessarily
about the idea of immigrants,
but I'm Muslim and there can be a
lot of directed aggression from Trump
supporters that I think I felt and other
people in my Muslim community have felt.
And that's why I'm here
sitting with you guys.
I own a clothing line, maggot
[inaudible]. This is my clothing line.
I'm a political strategist and a political
activist. And when I leave my house,
I am in fear for my life because
every day I get death threats.
So I think we both should be
able to freely express ourselves.
I love everybody. I'm here for everybody.
I'll fight for your right, for freedom.
But I expect for you to fight for mine
too, because that's why we're in America.
My name is [inaudible].
So I absolutely love immigration,
but I believe that we
need to secure our border.
And it's the same thing of I wouldn't
just let anyone in my car or in my house,
alright,
disagree has come on in.
I used to get anxious
about how I'm perceived,
not just by some quote unquote other side,
because my identity is very
apparent in standing in my truth.
I think it allows other folks to stand
in there as and to invite people to also
learn more about me rather than be
worried about how I'm perceived.
I think my group gets represented
unfairly in the media.
Yeah,
well I'm a Mexican and I hesitated
because when Trump said the things about
Mexicans been criminals and all that,
I,
I didn't took it personal because
I'm not that. So I was like,
that does not represent me.
Like don't take things personally.
So that's why I hesitated.
But then I'm like,
I am not only one Mexican
individual was an immigrant.
I'm part of all the immigrants no
matter what country you're from.
Or we can say the same thing for Trump
supporters. Right? I mean, now we have to,
maybe I wasn't called a racist, but you
are called racist. Well, guess what?
We're both Trump supporters.
So now we have to band together.
Could I, could I ask both of
you a question and I'd like it.
An honest reaction to this
in my mind is languaging.
I'm a writer and I think if we made a
distinction between jihadists and Muslims
that would solve
a big problem that's possible.
And I think a lot of that goes into
really the realm of how much people really
are interested and understanding
that kind of diversification and uh,
allowing the community that does
no, that really, um, I don't know,
take the lead and a initiative and
show other people what that's about.
I feel threatened by this presidency.
Oh,
that's interesting.
When president Trump got
elected as president,
I was scared even though I had not
a reason to because I'm legal here,
power becomes scary in hands of a monster.
Power becomes scary and hence of
ignorance and I'm scared about my people.
And not only, like I said,
the Mexicans, all the good
hardworking immigrants. Right.
Yeah. I think, um,
the election night was
when I felt alarmed.
I've been a community organizer and
an activist for 15 years now, right?
That night it felt like a slap in the
face to all of the work that we have
always tried to do in terms
of humanizing ourselves.
My name is Kyla shot.
I think we realize as immigrants how
lucky we are to be here and that's why we
want to create a society that's more
welcoming for others to be here.
You said it was a slap in the face,
and I take offense to that because you
were saying you worked so hard and yet we
worked so hard to,
to elect a president of the United States
that we think will enforce the laws,
will enforce the United
States constitution and it
wasn't to be racist or it
wasn't to boot you out of the country and
it was to enforce the first amendment.
It's actually to enforce
your freedom of speech.
I understand why you're scared
that as a white Trump supporter,
I am scared of this presidency because
I have lost my freedom of speech.
I have lost my freedom of religion.
I have lost my freedom to wear this
shirt in the public just because I have a
different political view.
Now.
I'm the enemy in my own country.
I think that that's unfortunate
about happened to you,
but it's almost like you
have some semblance of the
reality that people of color
live with for centuries here,
but I've never seen that and I've never
the first time you felt that. Right,
right. But I, I'm just going to let you,
no, that my neighbors are are black.
I have Muslim neighbors. I have,
I have neighbors of all kinds.
When we go to the grocery store
and I'm Picking Out Yogurt,
I'm picking out yogurt.
It looks like someone just like you,
but it doesn't mean that you
experienced the same thing as me,
even though we eat the same yogurt,
but nobody
in my county treats people
like that. It's just not. Thank
you.
Would be able to say that I lived in
Orange County up until a few months ago.
If I'm at a mall or if I'm
even at the beach. Right.
I get a lot of strange stares.
I even feel like a lot of people after
the election came up to me asking me
about my positions, my
religion, my identity.
So what I'm trying to say is like I can
actually relate to what you went through
because that to be honest is a shred of
similarity to what people of color have
always came here
when we were born basically.
Sure. I believe in immigration,
but I am against illegal immigration.
Yeah.
My whole thing is a assimilation,
right?
So like making sure
that the cultures match.
If you know someone in the Middle
East who's gay will be killed. Right.
That's the thing. And it's
horrible. If someone would,
that culture is somehow makes it through
vetting and comes here and then sees a
gay couple, you know, kissing or whatever,
they're going to freak out or they're
going to react very differently in a way
that, you know, we're trying to move past
or we're not trying to be held back by.
So I believe assimilation is probably
one of the most important factors of why
we need legal, not illegal,
immigrations. Okay.
My thing is about money or an awful lot
of people who came here legally don't
want illegal people being able
to come or get free college.
It costs $118 billion in welfare benefits.
That's a huge,
why do I have to pay so that
Walmart has cheap workers.
My name's Ken Unger. I don't have
anything against him. I crunch.
It's a political problem.
It's not an immigrant problem.
I was an illegal immigrant. I at one
point in my life, I am not anymore.
But ultimately we left the country of war,
a country where extremism
and terrorism was a reality.
And this is something that was on
a daily oppression towards women.
Um,
and if we don't have legal
immigration and we'll have that here,
we want you to come and be safe.
But don't you want that for everyone else?
Does it matter where you're coming from?
Okay.
I think it might be a misconstrued and,
or a misconception to think
that the illegal immigrants
might bring up the crime
rates. And when we're talking
about, uh, what happens, uh,
after immigrants or refugees or illegals
and anything come into the state and
how can we help them from here? I think
that is the real essential question.
We have a humanitarian duty to help one
another out regardless of f where I've
gotten a four, it's fairly,
if we're American, we're all
humans ultimately. Right?
So, fantastic. What about our backs? What
about our children that are starving?
What about our foster homes that are full?
What about them?
We're not helping them.
Where we're taking in all these refugees.
If we can't fix our citizens,
how can we fix others?
It's just kind of like, if I can't love
myself, I can't love another person.
It should be easier to
immigrate into America.
Hmm.
It should be easier. The wait
time should be shorter. Right?
But I believe that it's so lengthy.
Not because the process is so extreme.
I mean,
personally I think it's so
lengthy because it's mismanaged.
I think that like the cookie jar,
well that too,
but I think it's just like there's a
way in a process that should be put in
place. So it's not 15 years, let's
say that they fully cooperate. Right?
Let's say they have everything. They have
all their documents and they're ready.
Yeah.
I think it should be
be a lot shorter. You can make it less
bureaucratic. Yeah, basically. Okay.
I mean,
I think I would agree with that.
I just feel like when it comes to Trump,
you support the individual,
but then the bureaucracy,
the administration, all
of that is so painstaking,
just so inefficient. And in all of
this, it doesn't really compute for me.
I think I'm only been in
there a year. Right? Yeah.
And we have so many changes that we
want to make. So let's talk about
well, of policy things. What about
the Muslim man or the travel ban?
The travel ban to me was more of a,
well, it was something that was correct,
but it was enacted by Trump.
Don't, don't get me wrong.
I agree with the travel ban.
Right. And I agree with refugees,
but that's two separate things to me.
So what I'm trying to say is that none
of these policies that are happening are
not to do with one another.
They're all intertwined.
When we say we support the travel band,
but we also support refugees,
but we also want to like help them get
back to the nations and we also want to
do that. So we always want
to, well, don't forget,
we're funding the same bombs that
are causing the Yemenis to have to be
[inaudible].
I'm rob. There has to be a reason,
right? So it's all connected. Right?
So, so why are we bombing Yemen?
Personally, I haven't looked into Yemen.
I guess I'm missing your point.
Refugees. He support. Yes.
Travel ban. Muslim ban. You support.
It's not, it's not a Muslim. Yes,
I support a travel ban so we
can assess who's coming in.
I just think it's important to
contextualize like your thing.
Nothing happens in a vacuum.
Right.
And I think that if we start to actually
connect the dots like I'm encouraging
us to do, then it'll become a
lot more understandable. I mean,
I don't believe in bombing anyone.
I would like to answer your question
about why we're bombing Yemen.
We're not bombing Yemen were bombing
radical jihadists in Yemen who are killing
people.
That's why we're bombing parts of Yemen
selectively to kill people who are doing
terrible,
terrible things.
And there's a tremendous amount of rape
happening in England taking these little
girls, grooming them because they
feel they have the right to do.
We don't want that here. Those are things
we don't want in the United States.
And one of the things that's it,
predatory behavior,
excuse me, we don't want know if I
could say this and you'll get mad at me,
but if I could
say this,
it's not baked into their religion.
There are 109 passages in the Korean
where people are told to kill infidels and
and Christians and Jews.
There's nothing like that in our Bible
or the Bhagavad Gita or in anything
Buddha taught or any other religion
I'm aware of in the world until people
renounce those values,
right?
Then they scare me.
I don't think so. I haven't renounced
any part of my religion in front of you,
so I hope that you don't
feel threatened by me,
so I'm not sure what you mean by that
and I won't renounce any part of Islam.
The point that I'm trying to make is that
you didn't really answer the question.
No, he did. He said the reason why we're
bombing on Yemen is to save the people.
Cause I'm assuming that in Yemen and
we've got some bad guy to keep out.
People like that. Guys remember this,
a video of a Trump and immigrants.
We're mixing too much.
The religion, the race,
but you shouldn't question somebody's
religion. I am very religious,
very religious and I'm not putting
anything about my religion in here.
I'm here to talk about me as an immigrant.
What you guys are here to talk about
Donald Trump's like supporting him. Sure.
And yes, I've learned a lot. Like you
guys are human too. You have values.
You who would have thought,
you know,
that we would have found common ground
and we wouldn't like hit each other right
here. You know, because up there,
the media with train you guys as
bad or was this terrorist, whatever.
Right. I think the media is portraying
us all in a different light. Yeah.
I think that we're portraying ourselves
in a very different light too.
I mean I feel very attacked just now
for my religion when I did fix that.
Talking about myself as an immigrant.
Yes, that's what I'm saying.
You kept talking about the travel ban
is a Muslim ban that has to do with
immigration.
It's not a Muslim ban,
but what I'm trying to just say is that
no one should have to explain Muslim,
Christian, Jewish, none of
the above what they are too,
but Muslims continuously have to defend
not only their religion but their
humanity.
What I love about this country
is the diversity. I just,
when I came here from Mexico, I just
love how there was different religions,
different callers, different people. Like
it's amazing. It's, it's beautiful and I,
I don't,
I don't understand how empty I'm a human.
You have to be to discriminate someone
just because of their looks to assume
it's these preprogram thoughts in our
head from just media is what I believe.
Just blowing things out of proportion.
Just consistently,
just outlook on minorities or the
outlook on people in certain situations.
It's just bad.
Once you humanize someone,
when you're having a conversation and
I look past whatever these biases that
people try to enact on me.
Right?
Or of that I see and I started
looking at you as a person.
I start listening to what you're saying.
You really realize that it's not
that different. I mean we're just,
we have different situations,
we have different information,
but we're all trying
to do the best that way
have. I think the real interesting aspect
that I guess a lot of discrimination is
really about is taking this idea of the
phenomenon where you can associate
my case at least like Muslims,
terrorists equal each other and take
individuals and group them so easily with
that sort of discrimination and I think
that's something that we have to work
towards in terms of separating ourselves
from doing that. Thank you everybody.
I appreciate you all.
I was a great discussion.
Hey guys, thanks for watching that episode
of middle ground. My name is Taylor,
my name's Dan.
Please leave us a comment and let
us know your thoughts on this topic.
We'd love to hear some discussion going
on in the comments. Keep it friendly.
Keep it cool.
We love for you guys to get involved in
any way possible, so please subscribe.
Watch more videos, leave comments.
We live for that and a see you later.